[Aplausos]
alguna vez se preguntaron cuál es la
decisión más importante de su vida
de hecho realmente me interesa saber su
respuesta a quién de acá levante la mano
por favor alguna vez se hizo esta
pregunta
ok no estoy tan loco
entonces
para poder llegar a esa respuesta lo
primero que tenemos que entender es que
es una decisión inmediatamente después
qué significa que esa decisión sea
importante
una decisión es justamente la capacidad
de elegir o determinar algo para
nosotros para nuestra vida para nuestro
futuro
y lo más interesante es saber qué
significa importante
importante significa que existe una
jerarquía de valores y que hay cosas que
están por encima de otras y que por esa
razón esas cosas que se encuentran por
encima de otras deberían ser priorizadas
y deberían tener mucho deberían ser
tenidas en cuenta con mucho mayor
precisión y con mucho mayor precaución
y posiblemente mi forma de entender qué
es lo importante no sea la forma más
feliz quizás esto no les guste
pero para mí el hecho de que una
decisión pueda ser verdaderamente
importante lo que significa es que las
consecuencias
para ambos lados para bien y para mal
pueden ser muy extremas
entonces a partir de ahí empecé a
filosofar sobre sobre este punto de
cuáles son las decisiones que yo tomo en
mi vida que pueden tener consecuencias
tanto positivas como negativas
con el mayor impacto
yo no se puede pensar de repente pasa la
carrera que el hijo y si el hijo una
carrera y después no me gusta eso va a
tener un impacto y efectivamente esa es
mi historia elegí una carrera aunque
usted no lo crea yo estudiaba abogacía
y claramente eso no era para mí y
estudie ocho años equivocadamente
de repente una dice para el lugar donde
voy a vivir pero al final te puedes
tomar un vuelo te puedes mojar yo nací
en uruguay ahora estoy en mexico
recorrido más de 30 países de repente no
puede pensar para quizás es son los
hobbies que uno elige no pero los
hobbies también puede cambiar y de
repente si te gusta una cosa y mañana te
gusta otra y eso está 100% bien entonces
como llegué a esta pregunta
aunque ustedes no lo crean
antes yo era un completo inútil para
ligar
completo inútil era malísimo con las
mujeres no las entendía no sabían cómo
funcionaba no sabía cómo comunicarme no
sabía cómo hablarle a una mujer y
claramente lo único que sucedía cuando
yo tomaba esa iniciativa era el más
profundo rechazo
este rechazo genera claramente una
herida emocional en mí una herida que me
hace sentir extremadamente insuficiente
que hace sentir que algo me faltaba como
que había algo completamente roto ya
partir de ahí empecé a trabajar en ello
porque tenía dos opciones o eliminaba mi
existencia o resolvía ese problema para
mí era un problema verdaderamente
significativo entonces a partir de ahí
empecé a entender todo este mundo de las
habilidades sociales y de la seducción y
de las dinámicas sociales que
básicamente es entender el
comportamiento humano y saber cómo
hablarle una persona o como conocer en
mi caso cómo conocer a una mujer desde
un punto de vista atractivo y al día de
hoy tengo una empresa que se dedica
exactamente a eso nos dedicamos a
enseñar a los hombres a convertirse en
seres altamente atractivos para que
puedan encontrar a una mujer que
realmente les atraiga y que los
complemente como para quizás en el
futuro poder tener una relación a largo
plazo es mi segunda vez en un escenario
de teddy la primera charla fue sobre eso
y esta segunda viene a ser una especie
de continuación
entonces para mí la decisión más
importante que un hombre puede llegar a
tomar que una mujer incluso es el hecho
de saber qué tipo de relación que eres y
qué persona vas a elegir para esta
relación porque porque si llegas a meter
la pata en esta decisión las
consecuencias pueden ser fatales de
hecho recibimos miles de llamadas a la
semana y es muy común encontrar
historias de hombres que por haber
tomado mal esta decisión terminan
completamente arruinados eligieron de
repente una pareja que no lo
complementaba que no lo representaba que
por alguna causa motivo razón parece una
buena elección pero que no tomaron los
suficientes recaudos para saber si será
una buena elección a largo plazo
y a partir de ahí las consecuencias son
catastróficas porque muchas veces esas
parejas tienen hijos y aunque no lo
crean existen parejas que terminan
odiando a sus hijos por el simple hecho
de que se odian entre ellos por lo cual
las consecuencias de esa mala decisión
son transgeneracional es no solamente
afectan a tu vida sino que pueden
afectar a la de tus hijos y a partir de
ahí a las siguientes generaciones
entonces una relación bien diseñada y
con la persona correcta puede
potenciarse en absolutamente todos los
sentidos y mejorar tu calidad de vida
pero por el otro lado de la moneda por
la otra cara una relación improvisada
tiene el potencial de arruinarte por
completo en todas las áreas y creo que
acá absolutamente todos ustedes conocen
al menos una persona que esto le haya
pasado
entonces como surgen las relaciones
honestamente las relaciones surgen en su
gran mayoría de una forma improvisada un
hombre conoce a la mujer o una mujer a
una mujer a un hombre un hombre y
empiezan a salir
y a partir de ahí empiezan a convivir
cada vez más tiempo y como conviven más
tiempo empiezan a pensar y significa que
esto tenemos algo y como tenemos algo
mejor
convivimos y como convivimos a mejor nos
casábamos y como ya nos casamos a lo
mejor tenemos hijos y esto es 100%
improvisado
entonces como ustedes pueden prepararse
de la mejor forma posible para tomar
esta decisión de qué tipo de relación
quiero y con qué tipo de persona la
quiero
yo les quiero presentar 8 reglas que les
van a apoyar muchísimo a tomar una buena
decisión en este aspecto no significa
que les garantice el éxito pero es mucho
menos probable de tener un error fatal
en estas condiciones si ustedes acatan
estas 8 reglas que les quiero obsequiar
la primera regla es no esperes hacer un
hoyo en uno si no sabe jugar al golf
qué significa
muchas veces las personas
conocieron a una sola persona como
potencial pareja
y sienten muchas veces es por miedo a
perder en realidad sienten que esa es la
única persona que les va a dar que les
va dar importancia que les va a dar
cariño que les va a dar afecto y por esa
razón se aferran por completo a esa
persona
y eliminan la posibilidad de conocer a
otras personas y pretenden hacer un hoyo
en uno sin siquiera saber jugar al golf
claramente esto tiene consecuencias muy
pero muy complejas y en muchos casos
tristes
la segunda regla es que todo juego tiene
sus reglas
y el aprender seducción y habilidades
sociales lo que te permite es entender
existe algo llamado comportamiento
humano existe algo llamado por ejemplo
hombre y algo llamado mujer estas
personas tienen cierta polaridad que las
atrae hay cosas hay características de
la personalidad del físico de un montón
de cosas que hacen que una persona sea
más atractiva que otra
y ustedes no eligieron qué tipo de
persona les atrae
naturalmente tienen genético
genéticamente cargado determinadas
fórmulas que te dicen que esta persona
cuando uno ve por ejemplo como hombre ve
una mujer en la calle y se pasa esta
persona me llama muchísimo la atención
me gusta me parece súper atractiva y eso
no lo elegiste eso es es carga genética
que hace que vos puedas tomar una buena
decisión
desde un punto de vista de la especie de
lo que la especie homo sapiens se
necesita para seguir prevaleciendo la
tierra entonces si ustedes no aprenden
el juego ni siquiera están jugando que
significa si ustedes no aprenden
habilidades sociales no aprenden a
comunicarse no aprenden seducción es muy
probable que les sea mucho más difícil
lograr tener un buen resultado a la hora
de relacionarte con una pareja que si
las aprendieras y es algo que se puede
aprender 100% gratis con que ustedes
agarren y se pongan a buscar o en
youtube a leer libros o en algún caso el
que me quiera contratar como mentor
plasmáticas no es necesario pero si
necesitan informarse necesitan
informarse sobre qué es lo que le atrae
a una mujer o qué es lo que le atrae a
un hombre para poder encontrarlo en
ustedes mismos y aprender a entregarlo a
la persona de la forma adecuada
la regla número 3 es que para el mercado
de parejas tú eres tu único producto por
lo cual es preciso que te mejores no
podés cambiarlo si yo el día mañana me
pongo a vender tengo un emprendimiento
me pongo a vender esto y si quiero
cambiar y vender otra cosa lo puedo
hacer no hay absolutamente ningún
problema
pero si yo lo que estoy vendiendo que es
el producto más importante de mi vida
soy yo mismo y no soy capaz de vender
ese producto
eso me va a poner una encrucijada muy
pero muy difícil
para mí seducir es vender pero cuando
está seduciendo estás vendiendo el
producto más importante de tu vida que
sos vos mismo por lo cual si no sabes
seducir
no sabes vender absolutamente nada
la regla número 4 es que no puedes
asegurar que tu helado favorito es el de
fresa si sólo has probado ese
hay muchos hombres que me dicen yo
conocí a una mujer y esta mujer me
encanta y que no sé qué es la mejor y
que estoy del otro y le dio has tenido
oportunidad de conocer mujeres por
ejemplo de distintas culturas de otro
país de otra ciudad al menos
y me dicen que no y claramente están en
esas situaciones donde no saben lo que
no saben
por esa razón tiene que existir un
momento de experimentación ustedes como
seres humanos tienen que darse a la
tarea de experimentar y de conocer a
varias personas distintas y a partir de
ahí van a empezar a comprender cuáles
son las cosas que sí les cierran a
ustedes como persona y como pareja y
cuáles son las cosas que no iban a poder
distinguir la paja del trigo y van a
agarrar y decir che esto esto no me
convence esto no lo quiero y esto sí y
de esto quiero más entonces van a
empezar a afinar su puntería y se van a
convertir en francotiradores que pueden
realmente buscar a la mejor pareja
potencial que puedan llegar a encontrar
pero si ustedes no toman esta
determinación es completamente imposible
la regla número 5 es que no hay un buen
puerto para el que no sabe dónde va
tienen que definir exactamente qué tipo
de relación quieren existen un disparate
de tipos distintos de relación con
reglas distintas con acuerdos distintos
y ustedes tienen que saber cuál es el
vínculo que quieren desarrollar y cuáles
son los principios que van a ser
importantes para ese momento y para esa
relación
ahora sí una vez que sabemos cuál es el
vínculo tenemos que definir con
precisión qué tipo de persona encajaría
en esta relación y básicamente esto es
cómo hacer una lista del super quién
sabe hacer una lista del súper
ok es como tenemos que poner ahí todos
los elementos que nosotros buscamos en
nuestra potencial pareja quieren que les
comparta mi lista si o no
ok
necesitamos una lista exhaustiva tiene
que tener todo lo que necesitamos en mi
lista yo quiero una mujer libre
empoderada inteligente líder
emprendedora o empresaria con un físico
fitness buenas nalgas que le gustan los
deportes que quiera formar una familia
que sepa cocinar rico y sano que le
guste viajar que sea extrovertida y
social que sea muy abierta sexualmente
que le guste hablar de temas profundos
que no tenga tabúes que se hacían por
ciento auténtica que sea brutalmente
honesta que pueda enamorarse tanto de mi
sombra como de mi luz y este no es un
detalle menor y ustedes irán para cómo
hiciste clic que como puedes
encontrar una persona con esas
características decir huesos
completamente imposibles las noticias
que no aunque les parezca imposible esa
persona se llama alejandra está por ahí
y quiero que le demos un aplauso
profesor
y me queda una pequeña regla y muy
poquito tiempo y para esa regla me
gustaría invitar a ale si se anima a
pasar por acá creo que tenés que ir por
ahí y dar la vuelta
ya se sientes a patear
efe
la regla número 7 es que uno tiene que
ser 100% honesto con lo que uno quiere y
con lo que uno desea y poder
transmitírselo sin ningún tipo de temor
a la otra persona y siento que
esa regla de honestidad siempre la hemos
cumplido y hay una última regla conoces
a ese señor
señores jordan peterson es uno de mis
autores favoritos
y tiene una regla que dice
de shanghái siff sun game don't get to
play and lesión all in hay algunos
juegos a los que no se puede jugar si no
estás solo
y el amor es uno de ellos
alejandra limón flores tenés
absolutamente todo lo que yo busco en
una pareja es una mujer extraordinaria
hace días que no dejaron juntos
me gustaría casarte conmigo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchas gracias